welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
book reviews this is going to be a
little bit shorter than my usual fare in
part because the book that I'm reviewing
is indeed a much shorter book it's
actually a children's book the stock
horse and the stable Cat by Phil van
troyeren and it's published by stoic
simple press fables of eudaimonia and
that tells you kind of why I'm actually
reviewing the text normally I don't do
children's books but this one is
intended to teach some let's call it
basic principles and application of at
least a little bit of of stoic thought
and practice for kids and it was also
sent to me by the author himself with
the inscription choose to see the good
in life so you know it's it's very nice
that it was sent to me and I'm going to
make an exception to my usual focusing
on books written by adults for adults
and talk a bit about this the stock
horse and the stable cat
so I always like to begin every book
review with three big asses style
structure summary and so let's start
with style this is a kid's book after
all and it is written for children
um so it's rather formulaic in how it is
set out we'll talk about that a bit more
as we get into the main ideas of the
book I'll just say that there's sort of
a template for how the two main
characters the cat and the horse relate
to each other and you know it's written
in easy to read language I'm not sure
what grade level this would be
associated with but you know any
reasonably smart kid should be able to
make their way through it's not complex
vocabulary and I think you know the
repetition actually would you know make
it easier for a child to anticipate
what's coming next as far as the the
sentences the grammar all of that
one thing that we can say about it
that's really a central feature to it is
it is a picture book and so you can see
on the cover right here an image of the
aforementioned stock horse and stable
cat who turn out to be friends by the
way and we see some you know very
interesting depictions of what is going
on and I'll talk a little bit more about
these but I just want to give you a
quick vignette of what we're seeing in
them a number of what appear to be you
know paintings
some a little bit here's the cover one a
little bit more detail in some than in
others
sometimes human beings and other animals
in there as well like this guy for
example lots of nature scenes here's
another pretty one as well
the structure of it is that it's
basically
saying the same sort of thing page after
page after page and counter after
encounter until they get to the final
one which is you know a typical Kid's
book so you know nothing unusual there
and what is the summary well here's
where we get into a little bit of the
content
after we get past two quotations one
from Epictetus and one from William
Shakespeare it's not things that make us
feel upset but our judgments about
things and there's nothing either good
or bad but thinking makes it so we find
out that a faithful stock horse and a
Wily stable cat had become unlikely
friends at the ranch and found
themselves walking together one Autumn
morning and then that's the the lead up
right and then here's a sort of sample
page in a metal Behind The Paddock they
saw an apple tree and watched as its
branches rustled in a breeze
now the horse is going to have one take
the cat is going to have another the
wind is good said the stock horse it
carries the smell of Sagebrush from the
valley and blows through my main and
that makes me feel happy the wind is bad
so the stable cat it's boisterous and
bothersome and makes it difficult to
hunt mice in the field and that makes me
feel angry
so two different takes but the wind was
not good or bad it was simply the wind
and the horse and Cat were free to
choose how they felt about it so there's
there's your kind of summary of what's
going on
um many different iterations on that and
there's always going to be some feelings
involved they get to the very end I
suppose I should tell you that it's got
a happy ending or at least a you know
good ending
um you know they hang out with each
other the horse says we get to decide
for ourselves how things make us feel
and that is good and the stable cat says
yes you're right that's the greatest
good of all and then they part ways the
stock horse turned to walk back to the
Corral while the stable cat crept
silently off into the night so there's
you know essentially your summary of
what's going on in the book you could
say it's like basically like a a set of
encounters that these two animal friends
who seem to interestingly have very
contrary opinions and takes on so many
things this is how they they resolve
that seeming conflict
so main ideas of this work it is a
didactic work intended to help children
learn about some basic concepts that you
could say are not just coming from
stoicism but from ancient virtue ethics
in general where people are in fact held
responsible for the emotions that they
have because emotions have cognitive and
judgmental components as well as
affective components you're not going to
find any of that language in this book
of course because it's not written for
you know academics it is written for
children and so as I mentioned we have a
kind of formula that we see in each one
so X is good either the horse or the cat
says and it's good because of something
and that makes me feel a right and then
the other one very predictably will say
no no
X is bad and it's bad because of this
and that makes me feel B so there's like
a conflict of emotions there's a
interesting three-part shuffle for each
of these and you know it's easy to I
think wrap your head around for a kid
they can learn the lesson quite quickly
that not only are the same things going
to be viewed in different ways by
different animals and presumably by
extension different people but they're
going to have reasons for why they feel
that way reasons that matter to them but
maybe don't matter to the other person
and that is going to produce feelings on
their part which could be opposed to
each other so you know it's quite
interesting here if we look at the
feeling aspect of it so we've already
seen happy and angry right the next set
of paired feelings excited and worried
right this is about an apple tree
the cat bounded up the trunk of the
apple tree and walked out onto a branch
she sat and licked her paw contentively
while the horse looked up at her high
places are good high places is our ex I
can spy on everyone around me from up
here and that makes me feel excited high
places are bad so the stockhorse you
could hurt yourself if you fell from
there and that makes me feel worried
right so we've got excited worried
we've got an Apple apples make the horse
feel delighted make the cat feel
disgusted we've got a hollow log which
is a narrow space the cat if makes the
cat feel safe the horse likes being in
the open being cooped up makes the horse
feel nervous
the pond they encounter makes the horse
feel glad it makes the cat feel upset
because it imagines falling into the
water
they see the ranch his wife with goats
and the cat likes the goats it makes
them makes the cat feel cheerful
the goats the horses and so into them
the horse feels offended
then they see a Rancher doing hard work
the stock horse likes that it makes him
feel proud uh the cat hard work makes
the cat feel annoyed we get to
Reign and being alone and the cat likes
being alone and makes the cat feel free
the horse feels Lonesome instead we get
to the Ranch Dog Who the horse feels
grateful to and the cat instead feels
anxious we go a little bit further and
it is night night makes the cat feel
adventurous Knight makes the horse feel
frightened and that's basically it until
we get to the end where we'll talk about
that in just a moment so you see the
pattern there right there's a thing they
feel different ways about it and there's
another part of the formula whatever it
is is not good or bad it simply is that
thing and the horse and Cat were free to
choose how they felt about it now you
know
that's an interesting contention we'll
talk about that in a moment I do want to
talk about the very last set of points
that are being made here so you know
this ties directly into that the horse
is saying
we get to decide how things make us feel
that's good the stable cat thinks about
that that's the greatest good of all so
there's a claim being made you know it's
not being critically assessed or
anything like that because again
children's book right but something is
being put on the table as a main set of
points for understanding how we should
look at things in life and how we should
understand
the disagreements that we're going to
have with other people about those very
same things where do they come from it's
the way in which we choose to look at
things so this is a book that's intended
to you know enable children to come out
of let's call it being stuck with their
feelings being stuck with their mindsets
and offering them the Insight that we
are at least to some degree free to
choose how we look at things and then
that causes us to feel certain ways
so what are the good points about the
book I think that um van troyan is you
know a good descriptive writer I think
it can be quite difficult to write
in ways that are not generic that convey
you know the imagery of what's going on
that capture in this case you know the
character of a cat and a horse well and
I think that uh Venturian is actually
succeeded in that you know I'll just
give you uh
um a few examples right so the sun
climbed higher in the sky as the horse
and Cat passed through the meadow nice
descriptive language there they stopped
at the edge of a small pond and the
horse looked down at the mountains
reflected in the shallow water right wow
that's that's quite a vignette there
isn't it you could kind of linger over
that and imagine it in your mind and
this leads me to the second main thing
that I really do like about this book I
I really like the illustrations or
paintings including you know the cover
one right here which is associated with
that particular description of the you
know horse looking down and seeing the
mountains in the water
um you know art is rather subjective I
really do like this sort of style Rich
robust use of color and light kind of
impressionistic and parts I mean check
out this cat and the tree and then the
you know uh background right it's it's
not fully filled in but I like that sort
of thing myself here's another one of
the cat that I particularly like with
the hollow log that's a narrow space
right so I um I really like these and uh
here's here's a great one right they're
um anticipating the night where the cat
is going to feel adventurous watching
the sun go down together
um so yeah it's it's some great artwork
and you know I think the story reads
quite well I could imagine this being a
bedtime story for some child and getting
read over and over and over again so
yeah a few good things to say about this
was there anything that I found
problematic about the book I mean the
first time that I read it I thought oh
man this is really repetitious and
didactic and then you know I reread it
and also reminded myself that this is a
children's book this is not written for
adults or even teenagers this is written
for young kids and the more times that I
read it through the less problematic I
found the repetition of structure and
verbiage and
um you know the rather formulaic way
it's arranged I think actually that
turns out to be one of the strengths of
the book my only real concern is
something that comes not from within the
book but actually the back jacket
um where it's got this what does stoic
mean anyway
and it says stoicism is just a way of
looking at the world that makes you
happier it sounds simple because it is
stoic people try to focus only on good
emotions and accept the stuff they can't
change they believe every situation has
a silver lining and they try to be
perfectly content with what they already
have now the last two things those are
quite correct some of these things are
oversimplifications are actually quite
wrong about stoicism stoics don't just
focus on good emotions they also focus
on the bad emotions which is why they
have an entire theory about it and they
don't just ignore them they look at them
and try to figure out why they feel the
way that they do so that they can
eventually feel less of those they don't
just only focus on good emotions and so
that's that's misleading stoicism is not
just a way of looking at the world that
makes you happier that sounds simple
because it is stoicism is actually a
comp complex very you know robust
systematic philosophy with lots of
practices and insights and I think
telling kids that it's just a simple way
of looking at things is misleading
um how misleading not terribly because
if they're interested in stoicism they
can go so many places and quickly find
out that it's not just so simple a thing
I get that you know it's stoic simple
press and Phil Van troyeren is like
super into
stoicssimple.com but that's a whole
other conversation I think it's it's
problematic to make stoicism simpler
than it is you know it's sort of like
Occam's razor doesn't say the simplest
thing is the best Occam's razor says
don't multiply entities Beyond necessity
so if you need 29 explanatory principles
to actually explain something properly
you know reduce it to four just because
that's more convenient so that that's my
only real beef with the book
um I you know at first I kind of balled
looking at the price but apparently for
a hardcover children's book with lots of
illustrations it's a normal uh price
range for it and uh yeah that's that's
all I've got to say about it being
problematic
so final thoughts on the stock horse and
the stable Kent by Phil Van troyeren
um I like it I think it's it's quite
good I will try to think about who I can
give this to as a nice
present whose oven age that would
appreciate it because my kids are you
know much too old for this sort of thing
but I think it's you know it's a it's a
good children's book it's a nice Gateway
into a complex Rich very helpful
philosophy as a way of life that we call
stoicism it's a nice allegory for
teaching it and it was very nice that
Phil sent me this copy of his book to
take a look over and to pass on to
somebody else who might uh appreciate it
more maybe they'll pass it on over and
over and over again so that's it for
this very short review of the stock
horse and the stable cat